what's up dudes we are in orange county
we heard about a legit rager happening
we're super fired up we can't wait to
get in there and get it going
and staying safe stay safe
they get really into the music here
[Music]
have you accepted jesus before in your
heart
uh i don't know can i pray with you so
you accept jesus in your heart i just
want to rage at the moment but i'm down
to pray after are you guys with a cdc
oh no what's that is that a frat
we don't wear masks we believe in the
blood of jesus to give us to god to get
guys we're getting to be with jesus
christ what does it matter we live for
jesus christ if we die we enter eternity
so why fear death
only those who fear death will wear
things such as what you wear do you wear
a seat belt
um sometimes not all the time
nice